Speaker 1: Donald Trump is getting indicted
on 37 counts and he is facing a hypothetical
536 years in prison and some of his lawyers
have quit.
I am now going to catch you up on what is
going on with Donald Trump.
We had some of the information last week.
We now have more.
Trump charged with 37 counts in classified
documents.
Case indictment says.
Among other allegations.
The indictment says Trump showed classified
documents to other people in the summer of
2021 after leaving office.
The indictment was made public a day after
the grand jury charged Trump.
Two of Trump's lawyers resigned from representing
him in the classified documents case and in
another pending federal criminal investigation
into his efforts to overturn the loss in 2020.
Media eight Reporting Trump Maximum sentences
add up to a staggering 536 years in prison
for all counts.
I tell you this not to trick you into thinking
Trump might end up spending this much time
in prison or any time in prison at all.
I still believe the most likely outcome at
greater than 50% odds is that Trump will spend
no time in prison.
I tell you this to tell you the severity of
the totality of what Donald Trump has been
charged with.
So I want to talk about a few different things
here.
I'm not going to do a deep dive legal analysis
because I'm not a lawyer.
And there are many lawyers who can do the
deep dive legal analysis.
I'm going to give you an analysis of the politics
that is surrounding what is going on here.
Number one, there are so many of you who have
written to me and have said, David, sir, some
less politely, but many of you referring to
me as sir, saying this is it.
Right.
The Trumpists now are going to abandon Trump.
And the answer is absolutely not.
Look, look, the bee's knees.
Beasley is going to be on the ground for us
tomorrow in Miami interviewing Trump supporters.
And you are going to see not only are they
not abandoning Trump, they are flocking to
his defense.
The one remaining analysis that is valid for
what we are now seeing the defenses of Trump
from the MAGA cultists is the cult analysis
three books which I recommended on my live
stream over the weekend.
If you want to understand what is going on
with Trumpists are three books by the great
nonfiction author Jeff Glenn.
Jeff Glenn wrote a book about Charles Manson,
the leader of the family who died in prison
some years ago.
He wrote a book.
Jeff Gwinn wrote a book about Jim Jones, the
cult leader of the People's Temple.
That was the murder suicide involving the,
quote, Kool-Aid that so many people have heard
of.
And then David Koresh of the Branch Davidians
in Waco.
His most recent book is about that.
It is impossible, as I recently read Waco
and have previously read the other books.
It is impossible to read those books and not
see Trump ism in the descriptions of the cultists
and the cult loyalty that we see or we saw
to Koresh, Jones and Manson.
That is the most important analysis as far
as what we are seeing from the Trump supporters.
So then let's continue.
You are going to hear defenses of Trump from
cultists, but also from Republican hacks who
do this for a living.
You are going to hear all sorts of claims
about how this isn't really that serious and
there's really nothing here.
And what about Hillary and what about Hunter,
etc.?
The brazen nature of that which Trump is accused
of credibly.
We see evidence in the indictment.
Trump not cooperating on the classified documents,
moving documents around seemingly to evade
law enforcement, spending months refusing
to turn documents over, we found that the
surveillance room was flooded by a Mar a Lago
employee when they drained a pool into the
surveillance room, although they say that
was not deliberate.
But it is extraordinarily suspicious retention
of classified documents showing people classified
documents who don't have proper security clearances.
Trump has lied about every aspect of this.
He said, Oh, I declassified everything telepathically
or whatever.
But there are recordings of Trump saying,
I can't show you these documents because they're
classified, meaning he knew that he didn't
actually declassify them.
So there are many charges under the Espionage
Act, etc..
And we will leave it to the legal experts
to give you the bottom line on that.
You can make the argument, and I would defend
the argument, that we have a problem in the
United States with overclassification of documents.
We've talked about it before.
That's not an argument I'm afraid of.
But we are talking about very serious stuff
right here, documents related to military
capabilities, weapons capabilities about the
U.S. and other countries.
If Obama had done this, they would be saying
it's treason and it should be the death penalty.
Do not be confused for even a moment.
We don't know what Trump's memo.
Motive was we just don't know at this time
why was he keeping these documents?
One of the things we do know, based on the
pictures that have been released, is that
Donald Trump was keeping these documents in
boxes in his bathroom.
By the way, the bat.
I've told you before, money can't buy glass.
Trump's bathroom for rich guys just it's all
it's all crazy.
Okay?
It's every detail of this is insane.
But he had documents in the bathroom.
He had documents in his bedroom.
It's all completely whacked.
Another defense that you're hearing is that
these are technical crimes, process crimes.
Trump hasn't been given due process, but the
very same people saying that we're demanding
Hillary Clinton be jailed.
Absent any evidence of criminality, absent
an indictment, absent an adjudication, a conviction
and a sentencing, they were saying just do
not pass, go.
Do not collect $200, go straight to prison.
The very same people saying I'm for law and
order.
We're saying that or said lock up Joe Biden
or whatever.
And you've got pictures of Trump's bathroom
stuffed with boxes.
We have recorded conversations.
They want Hunter Biden jailed and yet we have
nothing on Hunter Biden that is even close
to what this indictment reveals they have
on Trump.
So you're going to see those people and those
very same people making these defenses might
show up tomorrow to riot outside the Miami
courthouse.
I hope that that doesn't happen.
But Trump and others have been in say, you
know, I guess there's really no other word
other than they've been inciting individuals
to go to Miami tomorrow.
We saw Mark Levin's delusional rant on Fox
News saying how how dare they indignant, how
they how dare they do this to Trump?
And it's really important to remember that
not only are these serious charges and not
only do they seem to have Trump dead to rights
pictures, audio recordings, all of it.
One of the other important things to think
about when it comes to this situation is that
this actually shows us we might have accountability
in a justice system that does have two tiers.
The two tiers aren't Democrats and Republicans.
Republicans are now saying this.
It's a two tiered justice system where if
you're a Trump supporter, there's different
rules.
No, the two tier justice system we've had
in this country for a long time is everybody
else.
And then the wealthy and the elite who get
the best, most expensive lawyers.
They don't have pretrial detention either
because it's not assigned or because they
can bail out, or that the two tiered justice
system has been that.
And what we are to take away from Trump getting
indicted is that no one is above the law.
Trump and others keep saying, if they can
do this to me, they're going to do it to you.
They're already doing it to the proverbial
you.
We know that.
The question was, can even someone in a position
like president be held accountable?
And at least as far as the indictment goes,
the answer might be yes.
We're going to talk about Judge Eileen Cannon
after the break.
And that's going to concern us in some ways.
Last thing, and I talked about this on my
stream, you might be wondering, am I going
to demand Trump's imprisonment for life or
something?
You might notice that in in the story so far,
I haven't said Trump should be in prison or
Trump should be in prison for X, Y, or Z amount
of time because that's not due process.
All I want is due process.
Okay, We had enough evidence to go to a grand
jury.
The grand jury said that said there is enough
evidence to indict.
So we've gotten an indictment.
So I'm not around here saying, oh, imprison
Trump for life.
What I want is now that there has been an
indictment, let's adjudicate it and depending
on its adjudication, either via a plea deal
or a guilty plea, a guilty verdict, rather,
then we can figure out what would be appropriate
sentencing.
And then let's talk about a sentence.
I actually support law and order.
I actually support due process.
I'm not going around demanding people be imprisoned
because I don't like their politics.
I don't like Trump's politics.
But what I want is the same thing that I want
for Hunter Biden.
If you believe he committed crimes for Hillary
Clinton or whatever the case may be.
Later in the program, we will talk about the
difference between the Trump classified document
indictment and what they wanted Hillary locked
up for.
And if you come with an open mind, I can only
imagine you will come away realizing there
is almost no comparison between the two.
Make sure you subscribe to the YouTube channel
at YouTube.com, slash the David Pakman show.
It is a massive program today, long and wide,
that I can assure you.